Blue Moon
now I'm no longer alone
without a dream in my heart
[Music]
Talent runs in the family that's Katie
Holmes's 16 year old daughter Suri
singing a cover of blue moon for her
2022 flick alone together it's nice to
talk John
now the actress is opening up about why
she recruited Surrey for the project
yeah it was really thrilling Katie poses
on the cover of glamor's April issue and
inside the mag she opens up about her
daughter whom she shares with her
ex-husband Tom Cruise not only does Suri
sing a cover of Frank Sinatra's Blue
Moon in the opening credits of the film
Katie wrote directed and starred in the
only one my arms will ever
[Music]
please Adore Me
let's go
turn to God
she also lends her vocal chops in
Katie's upcoming film rare objects
streaming on Voodoo Friday when did you
get out a couple days ago no one knows
you in the hospital right don't tell
anybody no I wasn't I wasn't planning on
it to Second Chances Katie tells the mag
she hopes her daughter always does
something on her movies adding that she
always asks her Katie explains that she
likes to include people she loves in her
projects where she says she creates a
safe beautiful creative space that's how
I like to work I like to have that kind
of feeling it was very meaningful to me
to have her there because she's my heart
I mean it was
a beautiful moment the simple things are
really beautiful and that is
those are the gifts of Life Katie will
celebrate surrey's 17th birthday on
April 18th and the Dawson's Creek Alum
shares rare Insight on raising her
teenage daughter because Suri was so
visible at a young age she really likes
to protect her I'm very grateful to be a
parent to be her parent she's an
incredible person I feel very proud but
Katie reveals her one regret not saving
some of her iconic outfits to pass down
to Surrey
I think the 90s style is exactly back
makes me feel old and while she may not
have saved those vintage threads back in
2017 Katie told E.T she has kept a few
gowns for Surrey your daughter is such a
fashionista also she's like a mini of
you did she approve the dress she she
loves this dress yes clearly Katie is
one proud mama and back in 2016 when
Katie made her directorial debut with
the drama all we had she dedicated the
film to Surrey she gets a special thanks
for everything every job I do because
she makes every day great and awesome
and and better and I know myself more
because of her so she'll always get a
special thanks
foreign